Leslie what was the timeline I know you
said you'd had to use some of your own
family savings for the film I don't know
at what point you're spending money to
hire these researchers but what's the
timeline you've set your family down
you've basically said I need to do this
and I just need your blessing okay so I
made the decision to make the film on
the twenty-third of December that I know
for sure of 2012 it was a week after the
incident Oh a week after okay and it was
the point at which I'd been watching
these extraordinarily beautiful sights
of protesters pouring out onto the
street and then on the twenty-third of
December is when the protests turned
violent because the police the
government decided to crack down on them
and that was when my the fire came into
my belly pretty much and I thought I'm
going to make a film about this and
there is no question i really want to
labor this point it's so important this
was the first time in my lifetime and
I'm 57 years old it's a long life it's
the first time in my lifetime that I
have seen any country including those
who call themselves civilized and
sophisticated who have gone out with so
much passion for women's rights I mean
the world has dealt with slavery it's
dealt with totalitarianism it's dealt
with race it's don't look so much but
it's still not dealt the question of
respect and the value of women and girls
so it's something that's very dear to my
heart and here was the India leading the
world by example on this that is why I I
absolutely felt I had to amplify those
voices with this film so 20 30 December
I decide to do it I think it was early
january when i sat my family down and
then i started reading and researching
and around may I wrote the letter to the
director general of Prisons to ask for
permission it took two weeks for her to
come back and say yes she then said she
needed to get permission from the
Ministry of Home Affairs because as a
foreign I wasn't allowed in indian jails
and she applied for that permission
asked me to slightly change my letter
which I did and the change she wanted
was that I had asked her precisely for
what I intended to do which was to
interview the these rapists she wanted
me to express that slightly more
generally for the Ministry of Home
Affairs and his a convicted rapists I
did that I got permission from the
Ministry of Home Affairs I got on a
plane in July and went to start filming
now the day before I left for the first
leg of the sheet because I I did three
legs of shoot from july to December I
shot and the day before I went off i
went to take a meeting on my literally
on my way out of London I went from
Copenhagen to London and then to india
and i took a meeting with channel and
BBC and channels were quite cynical in
their response to me they said get one
of the rapists get one of these
interviews and yes we're interested so
there are okay it's only if I get one of
the well of course everybody would be
interested if we got one of the rapist
so that didn't impress me much but when
I went to meet with nick fraser of the
BBC he was so supportive he opened up to
me as a human being and not just as a
cynical broadcaster and said this is a
very important film your passion is
palpable I like your vision for the film
and I want to support you now it takes
us a while to work out whether we'll
Commission something I cannot tell you
it'll be a while
however I do promise you that I'll
support you as Nick Fraser as an
individual I will come with you to heed
fur which is an important term
documentary market in Amsterdam and I'll
help you pitch it because he knew that
although I was a very experienced
feature film producer I had never done a
documentary I didn't know anyone in the
documentary world and I was immensely
touched and impressed by that so I
decided the BBC would definitely get it
if they said they'd commissioned it but
in the meantime it was pressing it was
urgent so I just went and carried on
shooting I didn't get any of the BBC
money until during the Edit and the
precious financially were huge they were
really huge at one point I literally had
to go into my children's school fees
account and empty that to carry on
shooting and at this point the BBC has
funded forty percent of the budget and
we did get thank heavens some support
from worldview development monies but
very small and the rest I have funded
and I'm still carrying that dead and i
understand to this date you've not made
a penny back on the film I've made some
value have a bank I have no going back
women make movies has very sweetly given
me an advance on you know their sales of
educational DVDs because they recognized
the fact that you know and I've also
been funding the campaign's out of my
own pocket so it's it's at the point now
where it's it's very critical and and I
absolutely have to raise money for the
campaign's in order to carry on the
education campaign in in particular but
you know I kind of feel this is what
I've been put on this earth to do and so
I'll do it by hook or by crook
you